final season of Two and a Half Men is
upon us Charlie Sheen has been out there
saying he wants to come back for like
the final episode or one of the final
episodes what's your take on that whole
thing you know I kind of I just kind of
stopped listening to things that Charlie
Sheen says like Charlie Sheen has become
like a parent on Charlie Brown to me
it's more like wah wah wah wah wah and I
just keep saying thank you for the great
job so I don't like I've got an awesome
job and it's thanks to you not having it
anymore so thank you right but wah wah
wah wah I'm just gonna keep going to
work and collecting the check yeah yeah
but if it happens it happens whatever I
don't even care like I think he's a
really wah wah wah yeah it's not a thing
for me okay we have a clip from Two and
a Half Men premiere yeah and I don't
even know if we need to set this up do
we do we really I mean I just looked at
Earth through the dome sorry hanging out
looking back at two and a Half Men Clips
take a look at this clip to name names
let me just say let me just hardly seen
is running the clip operation back there
and Charlie why are married people
automatically better parents
my mom's married six times didn't help
her see I would have been a great dad I
would have played catch with him I'm
gonna read to him I would have waited
till he went to sleep before I smoked
pot I already got my mom beat you
shouldn't give up you might still find
somebody I don't wanna marry somebody
just to marry somebody it's gotta be the
right person or Mila Kunis
[Applause]
you